Let's now look at how we might capture some layered facial performances.
So if you familiarize yourself with the animation blueprint of the MetaHuman, so we're in the
FaceAnimBP here that you can see is loaded, we can actually make a couple of additions
that allow a bit more user-friendly for when we're working inside of Unreal Engine.
So the first thing we want to do here, and we'll get closer into these details here in
a second, but just to give you an overview, the first thing we want to do is add the weighted
moving average with an alpha node to act as a denoiser.
And the second thing we'll do is that we'll add in a layered switch for selecting the
driving animation.
So if we look at the first setup here, we want to add the weighted moving average.
So all we need to do is promote the alpha, which you can see here, so just drag your
cursor from the green pin and drag it out and then let go.
And then you want to create a variable.
In this instance, we called it WMA alpha, but essentially you can rename it to whatever
you'd like.
You just want to make sure you compile your blueprint.
Once you've created a new variable, make sure you save it.
And then the default value here is going to be 0.8.
So just compile and save.
And then we have that alpha setup there.
And then we also want to make sure that we have the switch setup to switch between the
live link face data and also the body animation in the neck.
So this will allow us to alter the neck performance if we want to with the metahuman.
So essentially we begin by duplicating the layer blend per bone, body pose and use cache
body pose.
So you can see that we've got that duplicated there.
We want to rename the new body pose to face pose and then connect it to the open modify
curve in teeth controls.
I appreciate it.
Just listen to my voice.
It's going to be a little bit difficult to follow here.
Essentially we're just copying what we can see in the box here.
So in the layer blend per bone, we want to drag out from the blend pose 0 and create
the use cache pose, which is a face pose, and then duplicate that.
And then we just want to repeat the connections from the original layer blend per bone node
in the duplicated node.
So then we want to create a blend node, promote it to the alpha and to a variable and name
it llface, a live link face or anim neck switch.
And then we want to connect the original layer blend per bone nodes to the blend node, which
is the original to A and then duplicate to B.
And then we just want to connect the blend node to the local component node in the AR
kit.
And then once you've done all that, we can compile and save.
And then if we switch over to the event graph in this face and in BP, we can essentially
create an update here to the editor switch, which will allow us to preview the facial
performance without having to simulate the meta human, which is really nice update here.
So if we create update in editor as a bull, so you can see we've created a new bull here
that's called update in editor.
And if you just drag it out and select the get option, we'll create a get version of
this variable.
A little shortcut there is if you hold down control on your keyboard and left mouse drag
from the bull into the graph, it will automatically create a get.
And if you hold alt and left mouse drag from your variable into the event graph, you will
create a set variable.
So in case you want to speed up that process, that's a little shortcut for you.
So essentially, after creating this get node, we want to create a set update animation in
editor.
So first of all, we want to right click and create a get owning component, drag off that
and then type in set update animation in editor.
And then you'll be able to create that.
And then we just want to create a branch from this bull, go in from the blueprint update
animation, check that bull, connect the bull into the update state as well.
True will go into the update state and then false will return into the branch that was
already created in the set ARKit head rotation.
And then still in the event graph, we want to go to the end of the chain and find this
ARKit set up here.
And we want to copy this and then we want to move into our construction script that
you can see here on the right.
So we'll copy this, paste this or control C from the event graph, control V into the
construction script.
And then at the end of the construction, after the create a dynamic material instance, you
can plug that ARKit set up in there and then just plug that into the same node that we
were outputting the retarget set up there.
So we've just inserted this into the construction script.
And then lastly here, we want to go into the function, which is ARKit set up.
So that's what we're looking for.
You can find the functions on the left hand side of the blueprint.
So again, we want to create the update and editor a bullion if we haven't already got
one to then create a get into a set.
And we can drag in from the CAS to face anim blueprints.
So drag off there, we can create a as face anim BP pin searching for the set update and
editor.
And this creates a set update and editor node with a connected target.
And then also connect the get update and editor and set li-link face head to the set update
and editor.
And then you can compile and save.
And that is your complete setup for just modifying the MetaHuman blueprint for a little bit more
quality of life settings available to you inside the editor.
And then to get everything recorded, we'll use the take recorder again, or you can add
the MetaHuman blueprint actor to the source as you've done previously.
You can uncheck the MetaHuman BP actor recorded properties here, and then only check back
on the face recorded properties, the animation track and the transform track.
And that will give you the facial capture information you need for the performance.